العشره يتجمهرون حول بائع متجول حتى رحاله
في القريه
وهنا عاش السكان في عزله عن العالم تحت
امره الجيش الروسي قبل تقهوره الى الضفه
الاخرى من نهر الدين
قليل من الشحم لطبق الحساء لوجوه ارهقها
البرد الشديد رغم قطاع الكهرباء فان
الشتاء القارص ارحم له من الاحتلال الروسي
قلبوا حياه الناس راسا على عقب حطموا
المنازل التي كانت تحمين يخشى الناس من
عودتهم هذا امر مهم بالنسبه الينا واهم من
عوده الكهرباء اخيرا بوسعنا اخذون نفس
عميق نتمنى ان لا نرى هؤلاء الوحوش على
اراضينا ل 300 عام
يعاني بدل ان نعيش ان كان لديك الحطب
بوسعك التدفئه لاشهر لم يكن لدي حطب
وبالتالي اضيف غطاء وانام
قريه يعمرها شوي بسبب حمله الانتدابات
المكثفه قله من الشباب لم تلبي نداء ساحات
الحرب لم تبقى سواعد لزراعه الحقول التي
في جميع الحالات لا يمكن استغلالها جراء
الالغام طلبت الالغام التدخل فقالوا لي
انهم مشغولون للغايه وانهم سيعودون لتنظيف
حقلي في الخريف المقبل
في ضواحي خرس بدا الاوكرانيون في العوده
تدريجيا الى هذه المناطق المحرره اولئك
الذين اختاروا البقاء يعانون اليوم من
صدمه معاشوت تحت الاحتلال الروسي مع بروده
الطقس لم نلتقي في هذه القرى الا كبار
السن وقله قليله من الشباب
نحن هنا منذ البدايه عشنا كل شيء
الانفجارات التي كانت تضيء السماء كنا
نراها عبر النافذه رفضت ايلون المغادره
وترك والدتها انفقت مدخرتها لتدفئه الغرفه
الوحيده التي تاويها والتي تتقاسمها مع
والدتها وابنتها البكر وتوام الخمسه اشهر
فلو ديمير وفارا ولد تحت الاحتلال الروسي
عندما ولد لم يكن لدينا كهرباء
ان مات احدهما افضل ان يموت جميعنا بدل
المعاناه
[موسيقى]
بدا سكان قرى خرس في العوده بشكل بطيء من
لم يغادرها كائنا يعانق الحريه مجددا لكن
الجميع يدرك ان تقهر الروس لا يعني
بالضروره عوده الطمانينه